Ein US-Forschungsteam hat ein neues Modell
der Dunklen Materie entwickelt und eine kühne
These aufgestellt: Demnach könnten die Teilchen
der Dunklen Materie sogar schon vor dem eigentlichen
Urknall entstanden sein!
WHAT?!
Clixoom Science & Fiction - hier gibt es täglich
spannende Science-Videos, abonniert den Kanal
und aktiviert die Glocke nur dann verpasst
ihr nichts.
Los geht’s!
Herzlich willkommen!
Der US-Physiker Tommi Tenkanen von der John
Hopkins University ist - ebenfalls wie unzählige
andere Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler
weltweit - auf der intensiven Suche nach der
Dunklen Materie.
Doch er ist sich seiner Sache ganz sicher:
“Wenn die Dunkle Materie ein echtes Relikt
des Urknalls wäre, dann hätten Forscher
längst ein direktes Signal von ihr in verschiedenen
Teilchenphysik-Experimenten finden müssen“.
Laut Tenkanen ist also der Entstehungszeitpunkt
der entscheidende Knackpunkt und zudem auch
die Erklärung für alle bisherigen Fehlschläge
der Physik.
Und tatsächlich steht fest: Trotz intensiver
Suche konnten Forschungsteams weltweit keines
der möglichen Kandidaten wie Axione, SIMPs
oder WIMPs nachweisen.
Keines dieser möglichen Elementarteilen konnte
bisher dingfest gemacht werden, um so die
exotische Dunkle Materie zu erklären!
Die gängige Lehrmeinung geht davon aus, dass
die Dunkle Materie gemeinsam mit der Materie
entstanden ist.
Doch nach der Ansicht des US-Physikers Tenkanen
ist das ein Trugschluss.
In seiner aktuellen Studie stellt er ein Modell
vor, nach dem die Teilchen der Dunklen Materie
schon vor oder während der kosmischen Inflation
entstanden sind.
Eine spannende Annahme führt den Physiker
zu diesem Ergebnis.
Demnach beruht die Dunkle Materie auf einem
Skalarfeld und seinem Boson.
Zu vergleichen ist das in gewisser Weise mit
dem Higgs-Boson, dessen Skalarfeld der Materie
ihre Masse verleiht.
So könnte man sich laut Tenkanen also auch
den Einfluss des “dunklen” Skalarfeldes
auf die Dunkle Materie vorstellen.
Diese könnte nämlich - anders als gewöhnliche
Teilchen - schon vor oder während der Inflationsphase
entstanden sein.
Mit der kosmischen Inflation wird in der Fachsprache
die überlichtschnelle Ausdehnung bezeichnet,
die nicht nur den Kosmos, sondern auch die
Materie erzeugte.
Manchen Definitionen zufolge läutet die kosmische
Inflation quasi auch erst das Ende des Urknalls
sein.
Hierbei hat sich der Durchmesser des Universums
wohl in Bruchteilen einer Sekunden hundertmal
nacheinander verdoppelt.
Mit seiner kühnen Idee zur Entstehung der
Dunklen Materie ist der US-Physiker übrigens
gar nicht allein und erst Recht nicht der
Erste mit Gedanken dieser Art.
Schon andere Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler
vor ihm hatten ein Skalarfeld mit Boson als
Träger der Dunklen Materie angedacht.
Dazu der Physiker: “Wir zeigen erstmals,
dass ein Skalarfeld selbst im einfachsten
Fall alle Dunkle Materie hervorbringen kann,
ohne dass dies im Konflikt mit den Daten der
kosmischen Hintergrundstrahlung steht“.
Die Modelle des US-Forschungsteams legen nahe,
dass sich die Dunkle Materie tatsächlich
vor oder WÄHREND der Inflation gebildet haben
könnte.
Die Berechnungen zeigen, dass das dunkle Skalarfeld
dabei einen wichtigen Beitrag zur Strukturbildung
und zur Raumkrümmung im frühen Kosmos geleistet
hat.
Das entspricht tatsächlich auch den bisherigen
Modellen zur Dunklen Materie.
Dazu Tenkanen: “Mit dem von uns vorgeschlagenen
Szenario müssen wir zudem keine neuen Formen
der Wechselwirkung zwischen der sichtbaren
und Dunklen Materie einführen“.
Schon ab dem Jahr 2022 erhofft sich der Forscher
weitere Indizien und im besten Fall sogar
Belege für seine neue Hypothese.
Denn dann startet der ESA-Satellit “Euclid”
ins All.
Das Weltraumteleskop ist tatsächlich spezialisiert
darauf, die Expansion des Kosmos und auch
die Ursprünge der Materieverteilung ins Visier
zu nehmen Und die Verteilung von Galaxien
und anderer Materie im Kosmos könnte tatsächlich
wichtige Indizien bezüglich der neuen Ergebnisse
liefern.
Denn das neue Szenario von Tenkanen und seinem
Team ist keinesfalls durch Experimente der
Teilchenphysik zu überprüfen.
Dazu sind andere astronomische Beobachtungen
notwendig.
Denn falls es die Dunkle Materie tatsächlich
schon vor der Materie als Skalarfeld gegeben
haben sollte, hätte sie wohl Einfluss auf
deren Verteilung genommen.
Dazu Tenkanen: “„Es wird sehr spannend
sein zu sehen, was es über die Dunkle Materie
enthüllen wird und ob seine Daten uns einen
Blick in die Zeit vor dem Urknall gewähren”.
Dunkle Materie - die Suche nach dem Unsichtbaren
Anklicken, anschauen und Raumzeit- Vlog der
Zukunft abonnieren.
Nur noch ganz wenige Abos bis zu 100.000,
Raumzeit Vlog der Zukunft ist also kurz vor
dem silbernene Playbutton.
Also hier klicken und abonnieren.
Bis dann, bleibt dran!